- We Brusselin'. Everyday we Brusselin'.
Everyday we do Brusselin'.
(upbeat music)
- I hate Brussels sprouts.
- I think Brussels sprouts
are disgusting and terrible.
- I went out to dinner with
my friends from high school
a few months ago and they forced me
to try Brussels sprouts again.
It was covered in like garlic and bacon
and it was still disgusting.
- Being a vegetarian, I
think people often assume
that I'm typically always
down for Brussels sprouts.
Like any time I tell
people it's always this
like shocked reaction.
- I haven't really given it a fair shot,
but I don't know if I'm gonna give it
a fair shot today either.
(electronic music)
- My name is Ross Pineda,
currently the junior
sous chef at Pig and Cow.
- I am @HappyHealthyLatina, AKA Chef Yadi
and I'm the plant-based people chef.
I heard we have some picky
eaters with vegetables.
Brussels sprouts. Dun dun dun!
I think they have a
little bit of a bad rep.
We out here coming to bring
the Brussels to the hustle.
Let's get these haters out here
and turn them into lovers.
We hear you might have some vegetables
that are not your favorite.
- They've not had one
single Brussels sprout
that I've ever enjoyed.
- [Yadi] Not one?
- [Kyle] No.
- I think they smell terrible.
- Ooh they smell like what?
- Garbage.
- It's like a little baby cabbage.
It's like, "Hi!"
- Well I don't like
I don't like cabbage so.
- Like babies?
- I don't like babies. (laughing)
I am like beyond picky,
but it's all in my head.
It's all about texture.
- [Ross] Yes it is
- And temperature.
- What are some of the ways
you've eaten Brussels sprouts before?
- I've eaten it like the really gross way
where you just microwave them and then
put it out there.
- Wait, who, no.
What are some flavors that you like?
- [Ross] What makes you happy?
- I like spicy food a lot.
- Ooh, okay.
- I love crunchy things.
- I'm like a savory over
sweet kind of person.
- Savory over sweet.
- Are you a strict vegetarian?
- I eat seafood,
but that's it.
- Oh, okay.
It's gonna be alright, ready?
(loud exhaling)
May the odds be ever in our
flavor.
- Flavor.
(laughing)
(upbeat music)
- I love to mix in
sofrito Caribbean flavors.
Lots of spices and seasonings
that our contestants said that they loved.
So I'm gonna mix that with something
that they absolutely hate
which is Brussels sprouts
and see if we can, not hide it,
but celebrate and tuck
it at the same time.
I'm making a shaved Brussels slaw
with some red onions and then I'm making
a Brussels sprout slider,
and Old Bay Brussels chippies.
A lot of what people don't like
is like the texture and the shape
so by using this mandolin here
I've already deconstructed the shape
and we're gonna make it rain sprouts.
- I am making a Brussels sprout salad.
So it's practically deep
fried Brussels sprouts
with some cilantro, mint,
some chili-lime dressing
like Southeast Asian style.
Traditionally we use pork jowl
which is right under here,
but today I'm gonna be
using bacon and pancetta.
So I'm just trying to
bring all these flavors
so that people can understand
that Brussels sprouts
are not that bad.
And I understand that
we do have a vegetarian
in our panel of judges, but you don't have
to put in any meat in this salad
which is actually really good.
So you can stay healthy
and enjoy Brussels sprouts
at the same time.
I'm deep frying the Brussels sprouts
in just plain canola oil.
That takes away some of the bitterness
and when you hit it with the salt and acid
and all the herbs it really brings out
the best flavor it could possibly be.
- I brought my Caribbean flavors
with my homemade adobo and
sofrito inside of my panko.
Then I have my American
flavors with my slider
and my Brussels sprout fries
and now I'm bringing the Asian flavors
with what I'm doing to the shrimp.
I'm bringing some garlic, some honey,
some soy sauce, some ginger.
Pow pow pow.
That was a technical cooking term.
(upbeat music)
This is the American meets
Caribbean Brussels sprouts.
Everyday we hustlin', Brusselin plate.
You got your Brussels sprout slider,
your Old Bay Brussels sprout chippies,
a miso-maple butter sauce, a shaved slaw,
and some jalapeno in your face.
- I just pretty much made a
fried Brussels sprout salad.
I kept it Southeast
Asian with the flavors,
hit it with chili-lime dressing.
For my non-vegetarian homies
I put some bacon and pancetta lardons.
This is toasted rice powder.
It adds a little bit more extra flair
and we are done.
(intense electronic music)
- You don't even really taste
the Brussels sprouts in the patty.
- I said I like crunchy.
She listened to me, she
made it extra crunchy.
- I try to be the people's chef.
(intense electronic music)
- Mmm!
- It's sweet.
- At a restaurant someone put this down
I'd be like, "Hell no.
I'm not touching this,"
but it has really nice
flavor, really nice spice.
It's like sweet and savory
kinda mixed together.
- Exactly what I was going for.
- I'm diggin' it.
- First dish, so good, delicious.
I loved the texture of it,
especially the chippies on the side.
I thought it was great.
The second dish, when you
put that down on the table
I was like, "Hmm, cut!"
The pressure was on,
the cameras were rolling
so I took a bite and
I'm so glad that I did.
I just want blinders on 'cause I don't
wanna make anybody feel bad.
- Aw, come on. (laughing)
- The second dish is my favorite.
- As a vegetarian I'm always open
to different slider options
and this was delicious
and the chips on the side
were a really nice added bonus.
The second dish I also loved as well.
I'm a big fan of vegetables
and salads and everything.
While both were incredible, the creativity
of the first dish really
struck a chord with me.
That's my favorite.
- A slider is something I really like
and so to do like a
Brussels sprout take on it
was like really cool for me
and then the salad really shocked me
because I was like looking
at a full Brussels sprout
and I was, you expect me
to put this in my mouth?
But the flavors were amazing.
They were the spices all mixed together
and they were like savory and sweet,
but I think I have to go with the salad.
I was literally eating a Brussels sprout
straight up and it was
amazing and I was shocked.
I'm glad we got to
change your guys' minds.
- [All] Yeah!
- Can we get some Brussels
spirit fingers going here?
(laughing)
Everyday we Brusselin'.
- Yeah.
- So Chef Ross, did we
hustle for these Brussels?
- It's all in the muscle.
(electronic music)